all right you saw him on the podium
about 20 minutes ago and he his here in
the flesh with us at our setup at the
Indianapolis Convention Center McCabe
Becton Louisville tackle makai great to
see you pal we've also got Serena
Williams Chris Sims tried to fight
through it he went back in the hotel he
may be back later Shireen's gonna fill
in for a bit here but Makai hey I was
impressed by your answer I mean Straight
Talk no messing around you believe
you're the most dominant tackler of the
draft what have you experienced while
playing college football that makes you
believe that um just the way I dominate
the man in front of me these shows on
the tape every play I'm dominating
making sure he falls every play who have
you dominated the the most who's the guy
that you have just buried into the
ground every time you faced him Syracuse
Syracuse 4 so I don't really know us I
don't know his name off route but like
Syracuse for sure that's all I can say
it's the best guy you've gone against
Bradley took my freshman year what made
him so tough it's just he had different
type of moves that I haven't seen before
so I mean it was definitely a challenge
but I have four players yes officer are
you looking forward to getting a chance
to see him again at the next level yes
sir who's that one guy that when you see
him out on the field you're gonna say I
can't believe I am out here with that
guy
it's a lot of players it's a lot of
greats so it means it's really hard to
choose I would say uh and don't just see
him across the ball I'm beat
I'm you start strike at first and I'm
there's gonna be time to play did you
watch me tape on him
yeah I did I watched a little bit
Kenneth what do you think of his game
he's dominant real dominant he's really
dumb bleep later do you study any other
tackles see their moves see what they do
how much of that do you incorporate into
your game I incorporated lot I make sure
I always try to make sure my stance
don't show whatever play it is that's
what I read sniffed us and he like he
dominates real well as well I think you
trained at Michael Johnson right yes
ma'am what was it like learning from an
olympian 400 and 200 but but learning
from an Olympian what was that like it
was great because he taught him he
taught me how to run like um growing up
I wasn't running the right way yeah he
told me so it was great so I can't wait
what's your target and look III don't
want to hold you to it and I know you're
probably gonna want to aim a little
higher so it you come in under but what
give me give me just a rough idea of
what you're shooting for when you run a
five two five two five two loop five two
one below what about the the bench press
on the other side of the Curless 30-plus
listen I think you said freakish numbers
right every drill we're gonna have some
freakish numbers smell is it what what
drills are you bust in what's your worst
girlfriend best drill probably beautif
or T okay and my words to her probably
be the Hilger makka how old were you
when you made that first growth spurt
that has pushed you towards six foot
seven three hundred-plus like 1415
that's really when I started to hit my
growth spurt because it was one summer
it was like not summer but like my dad I
got me some sweatpants and then like
within weeks I needed some more
sweatpants good they were hot dad my
sweat pants or shorts now yeah that's
what happened do you have to work to
keep your weight on I know a lot of guys
you know the metabolism is still high
and they really got a fight there is it
natural for you no I mean at first the
problem of my way um I wasn't eating
because I will burn like 12-inch
calories and a workout and now I wasn't
replacing that food so that was really
my problem so now I'm learning to eat
more so that helped me out a lot
I don't think there's gonna be a problem
at all so you didn't eat mom and dad out
of house at home when you're growing up
not and I didn't really eat I wasn't
really a big eater when did you first
realize and where was it during a game
during a practice working out when did
you realize that you were gonna be a guy
who could make it to the NFL
might soothe great summer when I got my
first offer it's a Delaware State that's
when I figured out I can take this to
the next level who was it that that
contacted you and gave you the offer
from Delaware State you went to a Kemp
and I left with the offer so I don't
remember that that was like a while ago
so I don't think that stuff is even
there anymore so I don't really remember
that and then did you feel like you
carried yourself differently after that
like yeah I know I can do this sometimes
that confidence actually make sure
that's what oh you can do it that's half
the battle yeah I gained more confidence
that I got that first offer so I thought
that's what it was so where do you have
a target in mind a range a high-low
where you're gonna be drafted Salter I
think I'm gonna perform a little go talk
to who was your favorite team growing up
to watch no excuse
Brett see why the Redskins they was
close to home happening on from Richmond
so there was two hours away and then my
dad liked him too so I just like to
whoever my dad liked who was it that you
were a fan of specifically player wise
growing up who was the guy you loved
watching during games Clinton Portis who
was definite my favorite running back
LaDainian millennium Thomason was my
favorite running back to blowing up I
didn't really watch over Romney like
little kids been on they don't watch on
my Mac they watch the skill player so
that's what I grew up watching so
Washington had the Hogs do you know
anything about the Hogs back in the day
they got a decent offensive line now
tell you what they're drafting NP you
never know how it's gonna work out you
never know and that's the thing it's so
uncertain for everyone unlike College
where you get to pick where you're gonna
go you have to wait and see who looks
that call and I think it makes it even
more special when a guy gets to go to
the team that he grew up
for chance that happens that's pretty
hot chance he definitely happen
what's this week been like for you so
far been great I've been taking it in
it's a huge blessing just seeing these
different coaches talking to these
different teams is great it's a great
there's a great opportunity any crazy
questions that you've gotten so far ah
yeah
one guy actually no no I just had to
read one time I had Dori partying from a
scale of 1 to 10 that was the craziest
thing I ever did what was your answer 0
oh really like parties here's that
here's the key though what they do
during these sessions they try to get
under your skin to see when you're gonna
react
I wouldn't recommend doing that with you
364 don't try to get under this guy's
skin or you may end up regretting it
yeah probably all right well we're gonna
look forward to seeing you get under the
skin of some guys across from you in the
NFL we wish you all the best makak I
think you have a great combine we'll be
watching your 40 we'll be looking to see
what your numbers are in the benchpress
and we can't wait to see which team
drafts you and which team benefits from
six-foot-seven 364 pound like I've
backed in the loop
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports